e questa intro me la faccio da una
specie di quartiere americano che queste
sono ma tu regali a causa di delaunay
core
vabbè è andato a scoprire se il vicino è
veramente cattivo anyway oggi facciamo
un po di americane o facciamo un po di
pasta americane macron imax preghiera
sul canale dei vigili tv1 ragazzi a
partiti che oggi ha cucinato su un
simulatore un po di penne sono pene
quello che vedrete poi nel video
comunque assiste temi in cucina perché
merita buona visione ragazzi ingrediente
un 11 penne rigate 320 g penne rigate
vamos al alle penne le penne ci serve
eccole qua giulia penna penne rigate 320
all'ora specchio dei capi mettiamo
pomodori pelati pomodori 380 grammi
vamos mi sa che le misure sono fatto un
po amico però visione poi prendi tra i
pomodori facciamo un po meno facciamo
360 vabbè non importa come 23 pomodori
perché aglio uno spicchio solo taglio
quindi questo posso peperoncino secco
tre pezzi e per conoscenza ecco credo
che sia cuapio chi peperoncino quale poi
pronunciano secco quindi tre pezzi
33 agitate di perugia prezzemolo quello
di garda olio extravergine d'oliva
abbiamo tutto bene allora per preparare
le penne all'arrabbiata come prima cosa
scolate i pelati tutti quelli che non
hanno i capelli che guardo in questo
video via dalle palle poi trasferite in
una ciotola
non è vero venite che mi sapete e
schiacciateli con una forchetta
questo non è family friendly per
spezzettarli neanche questo a parte le
cagate dobbiamo schiacciare con una
forchetta i pomodori presa che ti dico
facciamo che li frulliamo chissenefrega
piatto frulliamo di como chissenefrega
di fare quello di dire lui proviamo lui
pomodoro metti tutto dentro
metti tutto dentro il contenitore di
coppito1 dos tres tres bon molto bene
una volta che abbiamo il nostro in true
c'è il nostro su go go bari
a questo punto tritate il peperoncino
già tritato a posto mettete sul fuoco
una pentola colma d'acqua salata piacere
a sentimento per la cultura araba sta
bene saliamo la pentola piacere sale
matthews al vai così vecchi acqua prendi
basta
per save dentro pentola di acqua di
pasta però non c'è diversa molto ben in
perfetto a posto di altri 20 minuto
buono via così la quando bolle non lo
metto il tempo quando parole modo poi
devo prendere un tegame e quindi questo
qua padella per faiella se ne frega
prendo un tegame e ci devo versare del
dell'olio a non aspetta su questo
integra me chissenefrega la paella la
paella come me dice via fuori dalla bona
e mettiamo il l'olio l'olio va l'olio
nella pentola l'olio è mezzo litro
d'olio unite lo spicchio d'aglio
sbucciato quindi prendiamo un attimo
l'aglio che già sbocciato posto quindi
mettiamo dentro o bene
una volta fatto questo il peperoncino
peperoncino allora dobbiamo lasciare
anche soffriggere quindi facciamo così
mettiamo qua accendiamo e facciamo
soffriggere nel mentre che metto il
peperoncino o fax mettiamo un po bassi
anche se xenserver nella famiglia una
volta messo il peperoncino
bisogna unire i pomodori quindi uniamo i
pomodori dentro qua siamo i pomodori
pomodoro
ap no no troppo ma pian piano pian pian
piano che un casino aspetto questo
style.it style i pomodori mescolare il
tutto ciò mescola perfetto perfetto bene
credo di aver mescolato abbassato via
via via fuori davanti
abbiamo fa ma come è possibile quando il
sugo sarà quasi cotto cuocere anche la
pasta al dente seguendo i tempi di pol
di cottura va bene quindi mettiamo un po
di pasta dami impianto per favore dammi
la pasta mettila qua dentro che capiamo
quanto dobbiamo mettere aspetti che
capisco no vabbè metteva sul bancone
perché la mia vita fa schifo qual è il
problema
mi hanno picchiato da piccolo non lo so
non capisco se pure beccato no non ci
credo dice bagatta se pure pagato ma
come mi si è variato gioco e lo stupro
della pasta
mio dio come un italiano si metta cucina
il soggiorno le cose ma porca vacca mi
sembra veramente abbiamo tutta la pasta
da versare dentro la pentola per poter
cuocere quindi by cuoci o al ct gli
occhi che si sta bruciava chievo di okc
perché non ho centrato bene tutta la
pentola la naja questi ci sono già che
ci siamo prendiamo pure questi vai cuoci
fai del tuo meglio o 340 precisi ed è
stato proprio bravo occhio sono andato
incredibile dopodiché una volta finita
la pasta devo impiattare tutto quindi
devo prendere un piatto profondo ma
secondo me non basta perché c'è troppa
roba quindi un piatto e devo già che ci
sono tagliare il prezzemolo aspetto che
qua sta finendo ma nei fatti non aveva
finito mi sono spaventato e l'aglio che
sta bruciando a marte prova bechi sempre
graglio bruciato ragazzi hanno bruciato
non importa a posto bene ora devo
scolare la pasta che non so bene
connessi scuole perché non ho losco lino
non ho ancora trovato io tutto sto
casino prova bene
usiamo il cervello per la friggitrice
per scolare la pasta teoricamente
dovrebbe funzionare privata funzionato
così quindi bo prendiamo questo anno
forse si scola anche senza sai se giro
piano piano la vacca piano a vedersi
scola anche senza fighissimo perfetto
scolate la pasta la pasta la mettiamo
dentro il piatto chiesto mamma mia
ragazzi mammamia signor cracco signor
crack che guarda sto video
ma cosa può mai aggiungere allora ho
rotto la finestra famiglia bisogna
tagliare il prezzemolo sono meraviglio
tritarlo il prezzemolo secondo me era
meglio
tritare il prezzo di richiamo e
prezzemolo a volte una volta tritate il
prezzemolo lo mettiamo un attimo da
parte abbiamo il nostro sugo con l'olio
bruciato mansuè buonissimo da mettere no
la hec contrario bene versali proprio
lui
se non sbaglio abbiamo finito manca solo
il prezzemolo che è qua che ovviamente
il 3 2 1
se è fantastic bene aggiungete il
prezzemolo mescola continuato e servite
le vostre penne all'arrabbiata ancora
calde o signori penne all'arrabbiata da
fa vj proprio lui che tiene il l'italia
e nel mentre stavo facendo così e non
era programmato che tiene l'italia alta
nel mondo cioè l'italia deve deve essere
rispettata nel mondo screenshot lo
salviamo signori penne all'arrabbiata da
fa vigente
talmente buono che è andato in crash
gioco ok anno le vuoi proprio piano che
è successo penne all'arrabbiata sì non
le vuoi perché perché non dovrebbero
piacerti spiega aspettano
[Musica]
no